i'm gonna stick to my coffee hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be talking all things powdered
greens and whether or not they're worth
the investment but first let me tell you
about my sponsor buildbar if you have
not hopped on this train yet get on it
these bars are my favorite they're
really unlike any other protein bar that
i've tried because they actually taste
more like a candy bar so not like chalky
or powdery or mealy or dry and there are
so many super fun flavors and i get a
lot of requests to talk about the puffs
which are a whole other line of good
times oh which one we gonna do
i'm feeling
like
banana cream pie
this is like a childhood dream of mine
with 17 grams of protein
[Music]
she actually tastes like pie oh my
goodness
and you know what i say about the zero
guilt thing unless you stole them from a
baby all foods are zero guilt so i love
these as like a bedtime snack or what
i'll do is i'll add them to like my
yogurt or my oatmeal just to bump up the
satiety factor and turn them into one of
my hunger crushing combos so if you want
to check these out yourself use my promo
code abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your
order and you can check out the link in
my description and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning for those with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating and if you are not already
subscribed hello hit that sub button and
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram at abby's kitchen all right
round up the troops influencer marketing
in the wellness space is pretty friggin
powerful and a perfect case study of
this is with the rise and popularity of
greens powders so this influencer-backed
supplement is often touted as a hack for
meeting your fruit and veggie needs
along with a laundry list of other
health claims like boosting energy
reducing bloating boosting your immune
system detoxing your body balancing
hormones slowing aging and of course
promoting weight loss just to name a few
now ingredients do vary from brand to
brand obviously but generally speaking
we're looking at a list of dehydrated
and powdered fruits and veggies extracts
vitamins minerals digestive enzymes
prebiotics probiotics herbs and other
plant-based ingredients in fact powdered
greens can contain up to 75 or more
different plant-based ingredients but
can we really solve all of our health
problems with a single jug of green
tinged water a day
um
well before we dig into the common
health claims i just want to note that
the evidence on powdered greens is
highly limited and most of the research
we do have is funded by the brand itself
or commercial seller of the product
which can create some bias in the
research there's also significant
variety in the specific ingredients and
amounts they contain making them
difficult to assess the category as a
whole so i'm just gonna work with the
evidence that we do have and look
specifically at some of the most common
ingredients that are used let's jump
into some of those claims number one it
improves our blood pressure so we
actually do have some research to
suggest that powdered greens may help
improve blood pressure for example one
small study found that daily intake of
greens powders specifically nano greens
helped to decrease blood pressure by
eight percent in folks with hypertension
but it's important to note that this
particular study was funded by biopharma
which is a company that sells nano green
supplements which of course like i said
may make the research subject to bias
however another study that was not
industry funded found similar blood
pressure lowering effects from daily
intake of greens powders in healthy
subjects while more research is needed
in this area we do know that higher
antioxidant intake may help to reduce
blood pressure markers and promote heart
health and considering powdered greens
are a concentrated source of
antioxidants it may be beneficial
however you can also totally get the
same effect just from eating a diet rich
in fruits and veg and that brings me to
claim number two greens powders boost
energy so powdered greens typically only
provide around 20 to 50 calories per
scoop now while you can certainly bump
up the calories by mixing it into a
smoothie or juice it is ultimately just
not an adequate replacement for actual
food so even though we are not getting
any significant energy boosting effects
from actual energy aka calories some
powdered greens are formulated with
green tea extract which of course
contains caffeine in fact one small
study found that women reported
increased energy levels after taking one
scoop of powdered greens with green tea
extract no
on the other hand other products may
have like an energy enhancing blend that
contains a variety of extracts powders
and amino acids however many of these
ingredients are either already produced
by the body naturally are readily
available from foods you're likely
eating or there is simply not enough
solid evidence to back up their use
ultimately you're better off getting
your energy from the most reliable og
source food next is clean number three
it boosts immunity
that smells like both many powdered
greens are often formulated with
vitamins like vitamin d zinc vitamin c
and selenium and they promise to boost
your immune system as a result but no
nutrient can boost your immune system
research suggests that in people who are
deficient in vitamin d supplementation
may help to lower the risk of
respiratory infections we also know that
vitamin c zinc and elderberry extract
may shorten the duration of a cold but
they're not likely so effective at
prevention some powdered greens will
also be formulated with an immune blend
with a variation of extracts like
astragalus garlic extract licorice root
echinacea etc however the research on
these ingredients is either mixed highly
limited or done exclusively on animals
in other words they may help support our
immune function but we need more solid
human research before we can recommend
them to boost anything it's also worth
pointing out that when these functional
ingredients do make their way onto an
ingredient panel in greens powder
they're usually in insignificant or
undisclosed amounts as part of
proprietary blends so even if the
ingredients were to have an impact on
immunity you're very likely getting way
too small of a dose to make it count
ultimately a lot of these powdered green
products are high in immune supporting
vitamins like any good multivitamin is
but these vitamins and minerals are
largely just adjuncts to adequate sleep
regular exercise stress management and
an overall balanced diet wow
crazy moving on to claim number four
greens powders improve digestion and gut
health some powdered greens are
formulated with ingredients intended to
promote gut health and aid bloating and
other symptoms of ibs so we do see a lot
of digestive enzymes probiotics
prebiotics and fiber added to them now
there definitely are clinical
indications for some added digestive
enzymes but they're also not necessary
for everyone with healthy functioning
guts it's also important to note that
some enzymes like bromelain which is a
very popular one in a lot of greens
supplements can interact with certain
medications like blood thinning meds so
always just run that by your doctor or
your pharmacist just in case just
because it's natural doesn't mean it's
benign roger roger as for probiotics i
am a fan of probiotics in general but i
also know that we have to be very
careful with strains depending on the
reason for your bloating or ibs some
strains may actually make bloating and
indigestion worse so again this is a
very individualized thing more
concerning to me is that while a lot of
influencers tout the anti-bloat benefits
i can see a lot of super bloating and
non-gut-friendly ingredients in this
list oh shocker mainly because they're
really high in fodmaps which can be
triggering for those with ibs fodmap
sensitivity or sibo for example so
ingredients like inulin fiber chicory
root extract garlic extract fructo
oligosaccharides apple powder asparagus
powder and shiitake mushroom powder are
all common sightings on these packages
and they're all common no-no's for a lot
of people dealing with persistent bloat
the other peculiar piece is the lack of
fiber greens powders are often seen as a
replacement for actual vegetables that
are good for your gut and sure if you're
fodmap sensitive i can see how consuming
less fiber from vegetables may
temporarily reduce bloating but as a
whole the best thing we can do to build
a healthy microbiome and to support gut
health is to get adequate fiber and most
powder greens products have only around
two grams now keep in mind most people
need between 25 and 38 grams of fiber
per day for regularity and other
benefits so i say add this to the list
of reasons why this is not an adequate
swap for actual food is it that obvious
i'm sorry with all that said while
powdered greens are unlikely to prevent
illness or drastically improve your
health they may still be a great add-on
to an already healthy balanced lifestyle
or may help to fill some nutritional
gaps and this is why i like to think of
them as a multivitamin in powdered form
and if you choose to opt for a green
space multi here are some things to look
for before you buy number one make sure
it's third party tested it's important
to look for whether the product is
third-party certified as this will
ensure that it has been tested for
quality and purity you can look up
supplements on websites like lab door
informed choice and nsf sport or check
the faq section of a brand's website or
if you still can't find info you can
also email the brand support team
directly and ask for proof of their
third party testing number two beware of
proprietary blends so i mentioned that
often brands will not disclose the
quantities of certain vitamins or
minerals and instead they just package
them under proprietary blends and i
understand the business reason for this
but as a consumer it means that you have
no idea how much of something is
actually in a product and whether it
yields a clinically effective dose
that's quite an accusation any response
seth
i always say that a piece of broccoli
could fart on a greens powder and they
could list it as an ingredient most of
the functional ingredients listed on
labels have clinical doses of between 1
to 10 grams each and since the scoop of
powder is generally in the 10 to 15 gram
range it's highly unlikely you're
getting a clinically relevant dose of
most of the ingredients you also could
hypothetically be getting a dangerously
high amount of an ingredient for you so
just like to keep in mind if you want to
know exactly what you're taking and
number three you want to avoid
sensationalized claims if the claim
sounds too good to be true it probably
is while supplements are not permitted
to be marketed with promises to treat
prevent or cure disease verbiage like
100
safe or zero side effects is also a bit
questionable in my books if a product
has the power to have a clinically
significant benefit it also comes with
risks and number four more is not
necessarily
more it is common for supplements to
provide nutrient quantities that are
significantly more than one's daily
needs and i know that we often see
things like 500 of your daily needs
intakes and think woo that's great more
is better but in some cases this may
actually do more harm than good for
example supplemental forms of vitamin c
are not excreted as easily from the body
compared to food sources and super high
amounts can also cause digestive
symptoms like diarrhea nausea and
abdominal cramps that's horrifying on
the other hand if you're already
obtaining enough of said vitamins from
food sources a supplemental high dose
will do nothing but create expensive pee
so when i see a lot of wellness
influencers using greens powders every
day and then following that up with like
a green smoothie and an avocado toast
and like a massive salad i'm like
you probably are not the kind of person
who might actually benefit from
something like this so again make sure
that you're reading ingredient labels
carefully especially if you are taking
other supplements on the side or getting
enough of these nutrients from food so
in conclusion while i think that
powdered greens can be a great way to
fill in nutritional gaps and get a
concentrated dose of antioxidants to
support overall health and well-being
they should be seen as multi-vitamins
not as a replacement for fruits and
vegetables in other words powdered
greens shouldn't be seen as the end-all
be-all to health and we should still be
prioritizing healthy lifestyle behaviors
like eating a balanced diet regular
exercise quality sleep and stress
management i know it's not as easy and
sexy and fast but if you enjoy the taste
of powdered greens you don't mind the
expense and they don't cause any
digestive discomfort or other side
effects then they can be totally used
within the context of a healthy
lifestyle and if not there are a lot of
other more budget-friendly multivitamins
or even just food that can provide the
same benefits for your health so on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
senior view next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]